نحن هنا على الحدود الشماليه مع لبنان
بالتزامن مع مناورات عسكريه اسرائيليه
تحاكي اندلاع حرب متعدده الجبهات فان
الجيش الاسرائيلي يبقي على حال تاهب قصوى
على الجبهه الشماليه مع لبنان وقد اخبر
سكان البلدات والمستوطنات الحدوديه بامكان
ان تندلع حرب قريبا وضروره اجلاء السكان
منها رغم ان المراقبين يستبعدون حدوث ذلك
قريبا لكن الجيش الاسرائيلي يواصل
التدريبات والتهديدات بامكان اندلاع
مواجهه مع حزب الله وهنا ايضا داخل مزارع
شبع المحتله يسود التوتر شديد بين الجيشين
الاسرائيلي واللبناني بسبب حفر اسرائيل
لخنادق في تلك المنطقه لكن الصوره تبقى
اعقد واكثر تركيبا بكثير اسرائيل تتحرك
وكان الحرب على الابواب لانها تدعي بان
ايران توشك على اخفاء البرنامج النووي
اللايراني بعمق كبير تحت الجبال بحيث يصبح
منيعا وحصينا امام الضربات حتى امام
القنابل الذكيه الخارقه للتحصينات
الامريكيه ما يعني ان هذه العمليه
العسكريه يجب ان تكون سريعه وعند التفكير
بذلك يتم التفكير بامكان ان تدلع حرب
شامله على الجبهه الشماليه زياد حلبي
العربيه محيط مزارع شبح